كل هؤلاء العرب يعطون أجواء التوكيه
يحلق الفكاهة بجانب الأسماء الأولى للغة
العربية نفسها التي يعتبرها
يتعارض مع العقلانية
اتباع مؤرخ متعصب
إيرنست رينان أو ال mcp
هذا لسانه المشدود اليوم بحسبه
ببساطة متجه
الانفصالية الإسلامية
خامس أكثر لغة منطوقة في
العالمية
اللغة العربية هي اللغة الثالثة
الاقتراض من الفرنسية وراء الإنجليزية
والإيطالية
لكن كل هذه الفكاهة لا تهتم
تجاهل أن هناك في اللغة
الفرنسي خمس مرات أكثر من الوفيات
من الكلمات السلتية لغة أسلافنا
و Vaudois الذين جميعهم 60
ألف كلمة تشكل جوهر
اللغة الفرنسية هناك 500 - الراب جيدا
أن في الصباح عند الإفطار أنت و
أربعة أشهر
لديك فنجان قهوة بالكلمة
عبث كلمة القهوة شهرين
ستضيف السكر إلى قهوتك
وكلمة هاموار الحلوة
بعد أن تأخذ عصير برتقال الكلمة
البرتقالي أيضا كلمة عربية
كانوا قادرين على الاستمتاع في كانط وكلمة ياسمين
هو لي كلمة الغيتار والهاموار
الخروف كلمة عربية
إنها أيضًا عشرات الكلمات
علماء الجبر كلمة خاصة العربية
خوارزمية الكلمة هي كلمة عربية
كيمياء الكلمة هي كلمة عربية
علامة @ التي نستخدمها في رسائل البريد الإلكتروني الخاصة بنا
إنها تأتي من الإسبانية إلى روبن الذي يأتي
هو نفسه من الكلمات الفنون رفرف
من مقياس الوزن القديم
اعتبر موسى بن ميمون العظيم
الرهان الثاني الذي كان طبيبه
هناك كتب عمله الرئيسي
دليل الضائع بالعربي الى العام
ألف 100 90
على بصمات اللسان
اللغة العربية الفرنسية أرسل لك مرة أخرى
إلى كتاب المعجم الرائع
سعر جان الفرنسية أسلافنا
العرب أيضا في كتاب
وزير الثقافة السابق و
التعليم الوطني جاك لانج
بعنوان كنز اللغة العربية
فرنسا
للأسف للسيد زمور
لحسن الحظ للبشرية
كلمة روايته للطيور ويكون عنده
لا يوجد جواز سفر أو تأشيرة مطلوبة
لاجل السفر
وحول موضوع اللغات سيمون
ليس فقط كاره للعرب
يقرأ أيضًا اللغة الإنجليزية
في 15 أكتوبر ونشرها في
تويتر نريد أن نحافظ على
أجمل لغة في العالم
واضح أننا نريد حمايتها منها
الثراء الأمريكي
المغاربية ومن الكتابة الشاملة
طوال تاريخها
لطالما كانت فرنسا أرضًا
حارة koulouris
حيث كل من اللهجات و
اللهجات
إلى جانب تاريخ فرنسا ليست كذلك
تاريخ اللغة الفرنسية
ولادة اللغة الفرنسية
يعود تاريخه إلى 842 وقسم
كان ستراسبورغ الصديق الطويل لآتا
من صباح اللغات الغالية
الجرماني
علاوة على ذلك مؤسس فرنسا اليورو
من قبل الجرماني التالي في الغناء
مطارق تشارلز العزيزة على سيدي
زمور الذي أوقف الفتح العربي في
poitiers عام 732 حيث حفيده
توج شارلمان إمبراطورًا في العام
800 شخصية ضخمة من العصور الوسطى الأوروبية
في مطالبة فرنسا وألمانيا
هذه الدراسة الأخيرة حول ما
معجب بالحضارة العربية
مسلم
في ماذا ولكن كل قصة
الفيل الأبيض في vonnas abbès who
كهدية دبلوماسية ل
شارلمان من قبل الخليفة العباسي
الصين
حول المعبود الأصفر والأخضر الذي تم استرداده بواسطة
أما اليمين المتطرف فلم يتكلم
فرنسي
علينا أن ننتظر القرن السادس عشر و
فرانسوا 1er حتى أن اللغة
أصبحت الفرنسية اللغة الرسمية
من الأمة
لقرون
لاتينية بريتون الفلمنكية
بورجوندي
بيكار بروفنسال جاسكون
تتعايش مع الفرنسية في كل شيء
السداسي
السيد الزموري أحادي اللغة له فقط
نافذة على العالم واللغة
الفرنسية وحيدة اللغة و أ
سجن طويل الأمد هل يعرف أن بول
روبرت الرجل الذي لعب دورًا رئيسيًا
في تاريخ القواميس
الفرنسية تفقد مسمى كبير و
عربة الجوالة الصغيرة والقدم السوداء ولكن في
الجزائر حيث أمضى 40 عامًا من حياته فيها
حصان بين اللغة الفرنسية و
اللغة العربية والانجليزية
للأسف إنه أيضًا زمور أصلي
الجزائري لن يستفيد من هذا
ثروة لغوية وثقافية لا
ما الذي سيفعله خيار أيديولوجي
والتي تتمثل في رفض أصولها
الأفريقي والبربر ل
استيعاب الهوية أثناء وجوده
لقب زمور هو كلمة
البربر ماذا يعني أوليفر
شجع أطفالك على التعلم
اللغات الأجنبية والانفتاح على
ثقافات أخرى إذا لم تكن رائعًا
ما زال يخبره بالثروة شارلمان
وجود جزيرة لغتنا
تملكنا
م